all right looks like we're now live for
the new AMA session
April 2018 I'm up here in the studio
with the Big Mac the one I do my video
editing and processing on not my laptop
which I've used in the past and I've
already got some questions lined up so
I'll be taking those in just a minute
before I do that for anybody who's
logged in and I see we've got 15 viewers
so far I'm gonna wish you that's cool
I'm gonna wish you a happy for 1/4 day
and I think a lot of people are gonna be
like what the hell is that what's he
talking about so that's a Milwaukee
thing right and a southeast Wisconsin
thing for one for was the area code when
I was a kid before cellphones existed
for the entire southeast Wisconsin area
around Milwaukee even out in the sticks
where I lived
we had interestingly enough adela field
address I went to Wales Elementary and
we had a Genesee Depot phone number so
for one four day four one four became
the the the area code for cell phones in
the Milwaukee area and everyone else
started using two one two and got a
little confusing for a while so for one
four day you know it's April 14th right
it's kind of a big thing in the
Milwaukee area there's a lot of like
little festivals here and there I'm sure
people have drink specials or something
like that all right so I'm actually
going to take one of the questions out
of order because it's specifically about
Milwaukee Carl bad if you're a true
Milwaukee guy you'll tell us your
opinion on George webs so I used to eat
at Georgia webs quite a bit when I lived
here in in the past and I like George
webs as a matter of fact there's one
over on Third Street that I take my kids
to and they're here in the summer and
sometimes the food is okay sometimes
it's great you know it all depends on
who's cooking in the kitchen but it's
you know it's an interesting part of the
Milwaukee area I mean
I remember going there when I was a kid
with my mom and dad so Carl says I
actually can tell you're legit cuz you
don't pronounce the L in Milwaukee
Milwaukee is always yeah yeah so alright
let me scroll up and start taking some
actual philosophies questions Carol also
when reading Plato's dialogue is there
any way to tell when we're getting
Socrates unmolested views as opposed to
Plato using him as a character or
mouthpiece that's a good question and so
that leads to what's called the Socratic
problem right how much of what we're
getting is straight Socrates and how
much of it is Plato either adding
something in or you know coloring things
or actually just inventing things and
saying that Socrates said them and we
could say similar things about some of
the other characters in Plato as well
because in the later dialogues you know
you've got other people who are
essentially Plato's mouthpiece so it all
depends on how you structure the
dialogues the scholars like to
distinguish between early middle and
late dialogues and they don't always
agree entirely about that in part
because there's a bit of a circle
involved in deciding which one's count
as you know in which area right I think
that sometimes it can be useful to look
at what Xenophon has to say said
Xenophon was also a student of Socrates
so where you get them both agreeing
that's probably right and in a lot of
cases it probably is more Plato than
Socrates you know scholars think that
Socrates probably didn't have a doctrine
of the forms
that's a platonic thing so when you see
Socrates referring to that you know that
could just be straight Plato and I
noticed I said the word could there
because again what is this based on this
is based on theories that they're using
as sort of a you know way of classifying
and and the theories themselves are
based on these stylistic and doctrinal
elements so there's a bit of circularity
there but you know for myself I'm not
that worried about the Socratic
because I'm more interested in the ideas
and their play but I think a lot of
people are quite worried because they
want to get the straight Socrates we
might actually think about like doing
something like a triangulation thinking
about you know what can you get from
Plato and Xenophon and then what can we
get from later sources that might
potentially be Socratic you know all
right let me take another one the proof
architect do I have any interest in any
topics in the philosophy of mathematics
like the feasibility of ZFC implications
of girdles incompleteness theorem
whether mathematics was invented or
discovered yeah you know I was actually
a math and philosophy major when I was
an undergraduate and I was very
interested in the foundations of logic
what was actually going on there how we
could model things and in in girdle's
incompleteness theorem we actually spent
an entire semester going through a
girdle Ashur by because it was a fairly
new book the Hofstadter book and I'm
looking at the mathematics involved in
that which was quite cool and I was you
know I was really I was interested in
sort of like the the metaphysics of
mathematics what are we actually playing
around with here I don't do much work
with it now in part because I don't
really have the time but it is an area
that I still have an interest in and
would love to carve out the time to you
know maybe do it do some videos or put
together a course on it that would be
kind of fun but you know the game that's
that's a matter I can sit here all day
and talk about the stuff I'd like to do
what there I actually get to do it
that's a different thing
Maxwell asks have you read Quentin may
assume and if so what do you think I
haven't read him so I don't have
anything I can say the proof architect
how did he who fights monsters quote
more recognized by its more literal
interpretation than a comment about
morality than cautioning us not to fall
into neol ism are both interpretations
compatible so the the the quote is from
Nietzsche he who fights monsters must
you know be careful not to become a
monster
so the concern here would be right if
you're if you're being a crusader about
something then you have a tendency to
also fall into that same sort of trap
very true right but fighting neol ism if
you fight me ilysm is there a danger of
you falling into nihilism and are both
of these interpretations compatible yeah
I mean compatible in the sense that you
could you could interpret it either way
I don't see them as contradictory to
each other so that works alright I
already got a lot of questions here so
six what do you think of Marxism or
dialectical materialism are there any
other revolutionary philosophy that came
after Marxism which explains everything
so I answer the last part first no there
aren't I don't think there's any
philosophy that explains everything
satisfactorily are there any
revolutionary philosophies that came
after Marxism that explains everything
no but it's not a question of whether
explains everything because that's a
really high bar you're always going to
be able to point out something that got
left out it's a question of adequacy is
it adequate to what we want philosophy
to be to be doing now what do I think
about Marxism I think Marx you know
brought out a lot of interesting ideas
some of which are I think quite correct
and and some of which are you know
clearly incorrect and you know the
notion of like this this straight path
through history
that that develops according to the
dialectical method and there's an
internal necessity to it I don't think
that's actually quite quite true but
with any theory we want to think about
does that that theory have resources
within it to adapt itself and still
remain in some respect true to its own
spirit you know I mean we could say the
same thing about Aristotle the remedy
for Aristotle's boneheaded remarks about
certain things is not to say oh forget
Aristotle
you read Aristotle against Aristotle
which you know some people say well
that's deconstruction but other people
say no that's just good hermeneutics
that's that's interpretation so yeah all
right
vintage watch guy do you have an opinion
on internal ISM versus external ISM
meaning tottenham I don't remember how
Putnam uses those terms those are terms
that that mean a million different
things depending on the context and
analytic philosophy so they mean one
thing in like you know philosophy of
action another thing and this another
thing and this another thing and this so
I don't I don't have opinions on that
because I always have to say okay what
do they actually mean by these terms
analytic philosophy is a little bit of a
rant very scholastic these days you know
they do it almost exactly what you know
the the Scholastic's were criticized
rightly by modern philosophers for doing
for attending more to train it you know
coin interesting new terminology that
the ordinary person is like what the
hell are you talking about and then
sticking to these very very you know
narrowly defined areas and saying well
that's that's that's philosophy that's
as good as we're gonna get and it's
interesting because you know not having
enough sort of reading of the back story
of philosophy I think a lot of analytics
don't recognize that Riley asks in
Cicero's on duties especially book five
what do you think Cicero's best
justification for the honess tome that
is the good in itself coinciding with
the utili is the useful right or the
expedient as its translated
are you convinced by it Thanks so you
know the Cicero's best justification
ultimately comes down to saying well
what's really going to be genuinely
beneficial for you useful is going to be
what is morally good and you're gonna
you know if you if you focus on what
people talk about is being useful or
expedient and it's in
with the good it's not really going to
be useful for you in the long run is
that convincing yeah I think in the malt
and the main it's convincing but you
don't have to necessarily have a stoic
perspective to say that the way he is in
that work all the proof architect here's
a follow up if you remember what courses
in mathematics did you take as an
undergraduate that's a good question
I know I took ten of them so I don't
know calc one two and three calc one was
really what made me want to become a
math major in the first place because we
started out unlike any I'll tell you a
little story here so I you know I was
good at mathematics as a kid and my dad
who was a tax attorney actually had an
early calculator and by the time I was
four years old he was already you know
teaching me mathematics and I was I was
learning you know a multiplication and
division and stuff like that and the
hook that he used to get me that they
actually do the problems and work with
him was I got to play with the
calculator I got to use the calculator
to check my results so by the time that
I got into elementary school and again I
was going out to a place you know in
Wales so really out in the countryside I
was already doing math at at you know a
pretty high level and they you know they
asked a question the first day like at
one time in class that the teacher said
what is you know four minus five and it
was supposed to be a trick question you
know there wasn't supposed to be a
correct answer for that cuz they hadn't
gone into negative numbers I was
negative one and so they're like okay
you go over there
and they gave me a fourth grade math
text and they said see these problems
here you think you can solve these go
ahead and do that and I just sat at my
own private desk and that's all I would
do during math class and so you know I
always tested very high in mathematics
but I never really gave a crap about it
you know and when I was in high school I
didn't have the intention of going to
college so
I took the math classes I needed to get
get him all the way right away I already
had algebra so I took geometry you know
with the the sophomores and then I took
like algebra 2 and trig and then I was
done with math so I was like great I
don't have to mess around with this and
part of it was because I'd never had
anybody who taught mathematics except
for my dad who of course you know died
when I was pretty young
who made mathematics interesting who
actually like started exploring what the
hell's going on with us so you know I
guess you could say I was the kind of
kid if there wasn't some sort of
metaphysics to it I couldn't care less
and when I got to that calc one class
professor Haas Ron Haas he started out
teaching us the theory of limits and I
was watching and doing this on the board
and I was like wow that's really
interesting stuff and then I went up to
him after class and I said so if if this
is the case then you know when you're
doing this asymptotic thing wouldn't it
also like do this on the other settings
like yes exactly and I was kind of
looked so yeah calc one two and three
I took a discrete math class and that's
kind of a catch-all you know a little
bit of logic a little bit of
combinatorics a little bit of this a
little bit of that
what else did I take number theory I
know I took complex analysis that that
special class what else linear algebra
geometry of course college geometry I
know I'm leaving something out and then
I actually did my senior thesis on
truths ultra referential statement
groups and found a mathematical modeling
for things like the liars paradox which
was kind of cool and then I I found a
geometrical modeling for it and
demonstrated that the mobius strip could
be used for that and that was actually
my writing sample that I sent out for
graduate school and I had one of the the
place where I went so they known our
University
Stephen time and said we didn't know
what the hell the make of that you know
we didn't know like whether you were
just crazy or or didn't understand when
a writing sample was quite funny all
right back to this um
Skyhawk gamers Plato or Aristotle why
not both yeah
you don't have to pick and pick and
choose the alt queerer what's the most
stoic literature you've read so I guess
you know what's the what's the and we're
leaving aside Stoics I guess right
because Senecas stoic you know Marcus
Aurelius between us there Stoics what is
the most stoic literature I've read I
mean it's tempting to say of course a
man in full because it's my doing
stoicism I don't know I'd have to think
about that one some more lonely jump to
another lit question from me smithy
myths TN piston men just bought the
Gulag Archipelago so that's referring to
Alexander Solzhenitsyn is Gulag
Archipelago has a three volume set of
essentially history of the Soviet gulag
system how did you like it when you read
it
well I'd already read some Solzhenitsyn
prior to that I'd read the first circle
and one day in the life of Ivan
Denisovich and there was something else
that I'd read and then I I found out
about the Gulag Archipelago and I bought
some copies at a used bookstore and I
started reading my way through it and I
thought holy crap this is fascinating
stuff and you know at that time that was
when I was in college and I was reading
other stuff too I was very interested in
the Russian Civil War especially because
you know some of us may not know this
but American troops were actually
involved in the Russian Civil War both
in siberia and up near you know like
Archangel and Murmansk and places like
that and the troops that were up there
in the winter in the frozen north
they were largely taken from Wisconsin
in Michigan
and so I was researching that quite a
bit you know I actually at one time
considered majoring in history but but I
was kind of eager to get the hell out of
college but I didn't do that I was
looking at doing a triple major because
philosophy mathematics and history
interestingly if I was to do some of the
philosophy classes I took would count as
history classes so it'd be feasible but
I just didn't get around to it but yeah
the Gulag Archipelago really good to
read it's a big investment of time and
energy but I think it's it's important
Sacco do you find in your readings that
there needs to be some sort of limits so
you won't be overwhelmed for example
even if you have lots on mine to cover
how can you narrow down to minimize
anxiety so not really an issue for me in
part because I don't get enough time to
read and I've been you know I've been
studying philosophy and reading widely
for most of my life the studying
philosophy since I was you know in in my
teens effectively in one way or another
and on the you know reading widely since
I was a kid so that that doesn't provoke
anxiety for me but I can understand how
it would for for others yeah you could
set limits tell yourself I'm gonna read
one chapter let's say you're doing
Epictetus discourses right why not just
read one chapter a day although some of
the chapters are quite long so you might
want to break them up and and you know
don't put too much stress on yourself
that you have to cover more and more
material there's always going to be more
time to read or if there isn't you're
gonna have other problems take your mind
off of the fact that you're not reading
so you don't have to put so much much on
your shoulders you could say salvitore
camp ode where Socrates and Plato a
preheater istic with probably Petter
istic couple no not at all if there is
anybody who's sake could have been
involved with that way it's Elsa by ADIZ
and we hear from you know ancient
sources that it was really Alcibiades
going after Socrates kassak rajee's
didn't sleep with them so so no there
wasn't any of that sort of thing going
on you know think platonic love right
you don't have sex with people
trevor writes what philosopher's do you
recommend for further reading I'm very
interested in moving the human zeitgeist
forward for the far future away from
profit for today towards long-term
survival well I don't think that you
know you necessarily have to be reading
new philosophers to consider those
themes because if you're going to try to
move humanity somewhere further then you
know you have to have an anthropology if
they have a understanding of human
nature and I think the ancients are
quite useful for that and the medievals
and so I mean there isn't anybody who I
would particularly recommend Sacco do
you find two losses treatment and reform
a philosophy to not to not be so
hierarchical anymore to have any merit I
I'm not a big fan of to lose you know I
mean I enjoy reading him he's kind of
you know weird and wacky and wild and I
like his critical essays but I got to
say I never really enjoy spending time
with the Lucien's and talking with them
about stuff because it's just rise on
this and you know this and this and this
and and you're like you're just you're
just repeating this can't you know give
me something with some real substance
you know and a lot of the critiques that
get made are kind of off base you know I
you know what I actually enjoy the most
about to lose I take that back it's not
just his critical essays it's the stuff
where he's looking at history of
philosophy like you know live in
liveness in the fold you know where his
book on on Nietzsche you know I like
that stuff you know you're getting more
to lose than you are the philosopher but
that's okay same thing with coach EV and
Hegel right you're you're not getting
straight Hegel with Coach eV
so I'm not you know I don't use to lose
much myself as a matter of fact one of
the long-term projects I would love if I
ever got the time to do I always wanted
to write a book cuz you know I really
cut my teeth in graduate school on
continental philosophy I would love to
write a book where I sort of look at key
figures in continental philosophy from
the 19th 20th and maybe even 21st
century and I'm like okay what's really
valuable in them and what's [ __ ]
because there's kind of a mix here you
know and and you know that would be kind
of fun to do you know there's good stuff
in dairy it out a lot of [ __ ] do
there's good stuff in Foucault there's
some [ __ ] - yeah and so I think I
would go through that as well all right
I'm gonna skip over the are you white or
Jewish question because you know that's
a really ridiculous thing the proof
architect by karl popper's falsification
principle experimentation is only
scientific if it has the possibility to
falsify previous theories does this mean
there is no room for novelty in science
no I mean first of all popper isn't
right above everything right so so maybe
you know his version of scientific is
not the only conception of scientific
that you'll find out there in the
philosophy of science and it's thought
it's often difficult to say what counts
is falsification for some theories and
is there no room for novelty in science
no it's constantly happening so all
right Ricky how would you describe the
Republic I'll give you a one line or a
must-read about when Socrates went down
to the Piraeus nice mist and then again
how much did you read when you were
younger
oh that's a great question a lot more
than I do
I don't get as much time to because you
know I do a lot of work and I think as
you get older somehow you just
accumulate so many responsibilities you
know I've got kids I've got I've got old
aging pets that have to be taken care of
you know you try to keep in touch with
your friends and your family and and get
get some other things done I do get you
know I do get some guilty pleasure
reading in because of the world's a
speculative fiction series that I've got
going so I'm going back and reading and
rereading sci-fi fantasy horror stuff
like that and occasionally reading some
new stuff that's new to me not new in
general when I was younger I was reading
all the time as a matter of fact I
remember as a kid again a lot of
anecdotes about when I was a kid this
time it seems I remember when I first
started to learn to read I was like
three years old and my mom you know my
mom and dad you know I was adopted and I
was adopted into a really great family
they spent the time with me to cultivate
my mind I learned I started reading when
I was three and then I started reading
street signs and I remember like being
in the car and reading every single
thing that's goodbye and finally my dad
telling me you've got to shut up you
can't keep reading all that stuff
because you're starting to you know
really get on my nerves a little bit of
reading that's fine read a book if you
want to but don't just keep saying what
every streets like yeah I mean I would I
would read like constantly when I was a
kid I'd go to the library you know our
local one and and just get book after
book after book and I would read pretty
voraciously the one thing I wouldn't do
typically was read what I was supposed
to read because quite frankly it seemed
like a lot of the books I was getting
assigned were kind of boring that's the
way the teachers were back then from
Greg Sadler fan that's that's nice
thoughts on William James and his work
the varieties of religious experiences
it's a great work I've taught that
before in philosophy of religion classes
I like it quite a bit
you know I'm a fan of James I think he's
quite interesting well I do more videos
with cliff
it's up to cliff if he if he asks me on
I think that he he started like that
that podcast but then didn't didn't
follow up with it you know so I did that
first one with him I don't know if he's
if he's continued it or not so you know
if he wants to do it I'm game Christian
I do you did you smoke oh yeah I love to
smoke you know and I never get to
anymore I started smoking cigarettes
when I was 17
yeah 17 years old and really loved it
came from a family of smokers too you
know when I was a kid and back then I
didn't like it but my mom and dad and
grandpa would all be smoking at the
dinner table I mean this is the 70s
right and my sister and I would be
sitting there in these clouds we'd be
like can you guys like wait until
dinner's over and then you know
predictably enough my sister and I
became smokers and I smoked through the
army and I smoked through college and
working and smoked through graduate
school and then I started you know
rolling my own and liking the taste of
like drama you know and then I I had a
friend who got me into cigars and after
I got into some guys was like screw
cigarettes you know these taste so much
better and it's so much more fun and you
get a bigger jolt of nicotine and for a
while I was in a cigar club you know and
when I was living in Indiana on my
family land my uncle who lived right
across the way from me he and I both had
humidors and we were both in this cigar
club so he'd get an order and then like
you know he'd order you know whatever he
got and I'd get an order beep like here
you need to try one of these a night for
a while I was smoking like sometimes two
or three cigars a day and that gets kind
of kind of you know pricey over time
it's not good for you so I cut back and
then eventually cut back more and more
and more until eventually I I really
don't smoke very often just when I'm
with friends
you know special occasions usually with
a with a good beer or you know scotch or
something like that to accompany it and
you know I smoked pot a few times never
really got that much into it and the
thing I really didn't like about pot
other than the smell was that you know
there's a bit of a generalization but
most pot heads are kind of boring
you know they just want to sit around
and and talk what they think it's
philosophy all day and you're like come
on let's go actually go do something you
know my drug of choice is always
drinking because at least if you drank
something would happen you know you go
out people get in a fight or you know
crazy things happens so yeah but those
days are mostly yeah I think all right
Rocco hi how was the study of philosophy
impact of your personal life would you
consider it
adding to overall quality yeah III would
say that you know I have derived a lot
of benefit from studying philosophers
I'll just give you one example and it's
one that's central to my research so I
do a lot of work on anger and people on
this have heard me talk about this a lot
of times so I'm not going to go through
a lot of more discussion about this but
you know the reason why I got into
studying philosophers on anger is
because you know I was struggling with
my own problems and I thought that
philosophical models might actually help
me understand it and deal with it and it
does help to some degree you know the
Stoics Aristotle people like that so
yeah
Maxwell Thompson Kurtz what is my
opinion of speculative realism generally
I don't really pay that much attention
to it you know I have one correspondent
who Evan talked with for a while who's
got a book out on it which is quite
interesting I've actually met Graham
Harman
at European graduate school and and you
know got to ask him a question during
his presentation I was a visiting
scholar there he did not want to talk
afterwards
so we didn't really have any interaction
and I I didn't see what they were doing
is really that that revolutionary are
interesting so you know but again I
haven't spent very much time with it
Sacco in the process of forming beliefs
and also avoiding ignorance and naivete
how can some make their way through the
history of philosophy what advice do you
have well what advice do I have for
forming beliefs and avoiding ignorance
and naivety I mean it helps I think to
read multiple points of view and take
them seriously for a while you know to
try them on imaginatively
as Alistair McIntyre says and you know
you you don't want to avoid particular
thinkers I'll tell you one thing if you
if you if you come to the history of
philosophy with a sort of schema in mind
like you know Whig what we call Whig
history you know or you know stuff that
you're getting from some some very
conservative interpretations or some
very liberal interpretations or you read
some philosopher who told you about all
the other previous philosophers you
probably want to put those things inside
when you actually go to to read them
because otherwise you get to the Stoics
and you're like well the stoic should be
saying this because so-and-so said that
about them and then you read them you're
like nope looks like they said something
very different
so you know I think that that could be
useful Christian why does Hegel have
such a bad reputation in today's mostly
analytical I guess philosophy
well almost anybody continental has a
bad reputation and analytic philosophy
just because of you know generations of
bad blood between the two of them Hegel
is is not a great writer
he's often more obscure than he needs to
be particularly in the phenomenology
which is what you know in the 20th
century I think most people tended to
focus on and so you know it's not going
to fit nicely into analytic philosophy
gotta remember too that early Annalee
analytic philosophy was a reaction
against British agalya's as well all
right
so there's already some animus at the
start but I mean I don't think analytics
dislike Hegel any more than they dislike
Heidegger or Derrida or Foucault most of
the time
much of the dislike is off-target
because they don't even know what what
these people have said and they've made
you know some very short and abortive
attempts to read them in part because
the kind of style of reading that you do
that you're trained in an analytic
philosophy is not really conducive to
reading you know full texts and and
thinking about you know the sort of
comprehensive scope and the thinker's
works it also makes it makes it hard for
you to read Aristotle well or the Stoics
or Descartes whoever right so I wouldn't
I wouldn't hold that you know the Hegel
thing particularly against them and you
know in even in continental philosophy I
would say most people don't really read
much Hegel and don't understand Hegel
very well other than you know looking at
the master-slave dialectic just like
most people that talk about Lacan talk
about the mirror stage and then they
don't read anything else so of course
they get it wrong you know so you know
this is kind of a common common issue
Tristan do you think you gain anything
from philosophy schooling versus
studying it on your own totally depends
on where you're studying and who you're
studying with and what your temperament
is like I know for me I very much
benefited from benign neglect you know
being allowed to go study on my own and
read what I wanted to read and and run
into people but it was good for me to
run into some people and
with them about stuff and get
recommendations i was also the kind of
person who would often say oh you know
this person seems pretty well put
together and they think that so-and-so
and so-and-so is worth reading I'll go
read them now you know and I'd also you
know do sort of it was not great great
reasoning but I'd be like wow that
person's a jerk and they're really into
so-and-so I wonder if that has anything
to do with it I probably don't need to
bother reading so-and-so so you know you
you can certainly go on your own but it
can be very helpful to go study with
with other people but it's kind of a
mixed bag you know academic philosophy
settings they're primarily oriented
towards churning out new PhDs to go
teach in jobs that don't exist so they
don't you know it's not very adaptive
it's kind of dysfunctional but there's
plenty of ways to study aidid you know
by people on the internet you know like
or or face-to-face you know I'll give
you two examples here in Milwaukee we
have a MKE stoic fellowship that meets
monthly right now we're reading through
Senecas letters and we talk about what
we got out of them and you know how it
applies to our lives and it's great to
do that you know we also have the
Milwaukee Sofia chapter that's a Society
of philosophers in America our first
event last month we've got some other
events coming up this year so those are
opportunities to get together with with
people who are interested in philosophy
face-to-face and in most cities these
days you can find something like that
now it might be flaky people we're I
think it but you never know until you
actually try proof architect what
understandings of Hegel's philosophy do
you need to know to understand
Kierkegaard's fear and trembling what
sections of your half-hour Hegel videos
list do you recommend I look at none
I mean Kierkegaard is is not really
reacting to the phenomenology he is
reacting to the Hegelian ism on his time
and I if I was gonna pick something
I would say could be helpful it would
probably be to look at Hegel's lectures
on the philosophy of religion more than
done you know any of the other major
works but it's also important to
remember that hi that that although he
mentions Hegel he's really reacting to
Hegelian ISM more than Hegel himself
there's a great question by Jo Jo oniton
no new gusto I don't know if I'm reading
an umlaut there right or not or a tilde
as an academic what do you think about
the alleged neoliberal ization of
academia do you think universities are
becoming merely an instrument for
material gain and losing their free
character well in my experience most of
them aren't free anyway so you know I
guess in other places they often do have
free schooling but that's not the case
here in the United States there were
some interesting exceptions I think the
CUNY City University of New York was was
free for a while California had free
education for a while but that's that's
like generations ago I think there is a
neoliberal ization going on within
academia and that's what kind of a
loosey-goosey term but it means you know
turning universities into essentially
things like corporations and turning
professors into just employees and
focusing much more on metrics than on
real education yeah that's going on and
and the you know the cost-cutting
measures that have resulted in many
people just only having access to
adjunct jobs which it really sucks if
that's all you've got you know you don't
have a side gig to work on it's a tough
life even having like a one-year
position and going to the next one year
position over and over again wears you
out and you know who's benefited from it
the administrators you know and the
trustees I would say in many places the
board
of Trustees have been terrible and in
guiding university policy and I mean you
can still do good research and good
teaching within a university setting
it's not as if just because of the the
institution is a certain way that you
can't do a good job within it
but you know it's tougher alright Nevis
America Sir what about objectivism so
that's what about Iran's philosophy
which has a number of different
interpreters and institutions out there
talking about it I'd say it's you know
it's a it's a it's a philosophy but it's
not a particularly good one
you know Rand was a terrible historian
of philosophy who was perfectly willing
to give all sorts of opinions about it
where she does tend to have some things
that are interesting or right you can
usually find those and other
philosophers you know so for example she
talks about the notion of hierarchy of
values well look that's cool you know
it's important to prioritize but you
might you know check out mock Schaller
or Dietrich on Hildebrand or somebody
else for talking about hierarchies of
values and so you know I think she's
important to teach in part because
there's so many people who take her
seriously not just here in the United
States but also in parts of the
developing world but I don't I don't
consider her a particularly good
philosopher Thomas Fortunato I wish
philosophy were explained in less of the
gaseous way I don't even know what
gaseous would mean so if what you're
doing is complaining about the way most
people in academia tend to explain
philosophy or portray it you're probably
right it's not I complain a lot about my
peers and say many of them have no
interest whatsoever in in connecting
even with fellow academics you know
they're doing their own little thing and
they think it's important this is part
of why the neoliberalism thing was so
easy to come in because in not just
philosophers academics we're not doing a
good job in holding the line against
that
nice misty and why do you think we need
philosophy today for the same reasons as
we've needed it for four millennia
it's a among other things it provides us
with a way of understanding the various
fields in a synthetic manner and it lets
us understand who we are and and make
important decisions about what we want
to change in ourselves so wow this is a
very specific question how would i rank
these actions in term from sinfulness
from least to worst murder hiring an
assassin to kill someone suicide to
frame someone for murder murder suicide
like suicide bombers I mean just taking
a stab at it because this is something
you really would have to think about
more right I guess you know hiring an
assassin to kill someone is that worse
than the murder in some respects it is
because you're bringing more people into
it and you have the same intent for them
to to die suicide to frame someone for
murder seems kind of lower than hiring
an assassin I don't have good reasons
for saying that's murder suicide like
suicide bombers well you're definitely
trying to take out a lot more people so
that's that's that's worse in a way oh
here's a good question from western man
what was it about the Nazi regime that
seduced Heidegger to their cause to the
point where he was unrepentant years
later well I don't know that well but
you know clearly he did think that that
the Nazi movement and Hitler himself as
the Fuhrer were as he called it the
voice of being and he's reacting I think
it part of it is this is why a lot of
people get drawn into movements he was
reacting against all these things that
are happening within modern Western
thought and politics and culture that
the Nazis were all
so against at least in theory sometimes
not not when push came to shove you know
like when it came to like actually
resisting capitalism the Nazis were more
talk than action so I think that's part
of what what drew him into it and I
think he liked a lot of Germans at that
time you know felt like well listen our
side lost but that doesn't mean that the
ideas were bad that just means you wound
up with more force because you have you
know Russia the whole British Empire and
America and various other things you
know on your side and he did remain
unrepentant that's that's quite true
Skyhawk gamers would you consider
yourself a naturalist or
supernaturalists I don't use terms like
that I mean I don't think it makes I
you'd have to tell me where the dividing
line is I probably would say I'm I
consider myself a supernaturalists
because I don't think that most versions
of naturalism adequately cover all the
stuff that we have to deal with but
there could be varieties of naturalism
out there that are better this is
something that came up in in the the
interview with Matt flam about Santayana
and naturalism all right Adam how to
stop hating yourself and being arrogant
is existentialism help with it I guess
it could I could also like exacerbate it
depending on how you're eating it right
your reinsert and you're like I'm so
cool because I can read Sartre and you
can't well that's gonna lead the
arrogance right but hating yourself and
being arrogant I mean those usually
don't go hand in hand usually it's more
like you know you hate yourself so you
kind of go down I suppose it could be a
compensation thing right but would
existentialism in particular help I
don't I don't really think so I mean I
would imagine if it did it would
probably be less art or Camus and
or somebody like Marcel or reading
Simone de Beauvoir so maybe you want to
check out those authors Hayley I'm
writing a paper on manual labor and
stoic philosophy would love to know your
thoughts so the Stoics thought there was
nothing wrong with manual labor as a
matter of fact cruciferous the second
Skol arc worked as a water carrier which
is kind of low on the scale right and
they they saw you know there wasn't
really any any problem with doing manual
labor you're using your body and it
depends on you know where you you fit in
there's also nothing wrong with not
doing manual labor if you don't have to
[Music]
Benton's watch guys meaning in our mind
or in the external world both you know
meaning is partly in in our relations
with other people too right there in the
external world we have an interest
objective relationship with them so you
know it's it's uh it's all connected up
with each other
Yoga I'm sure I'm mispronouncing that
how to determine whether someone
possesses a virtue or not how can i
telephone temperate for example look at
your action over time start start
keeping a journal and you're also going
to need some theory to make some sense
of that right so decide whose theory you
want to use maybe Aristotle maybe you
know Plutarch it was a neoplatonist
maybe the Stoics maybe some Christian
authors I don't know it depends on whose
conception of temperance you want and
then start looking at your motivational
structure and that's how you can start
to tell Gerrit asks about Marx I already
talked about Marx earlier but he brings
up are you familiar with his works in
depth I've studied Marx and depth yeah
it's not somebody who I routinely read a
lot of these days but that's in part
because I I don't I don't have much of a
chance to coach each other's your IQ I
don't know I mean in the last IQ test I
had I was probably 16 or so and
iq is mostly kind of a BS measure anyway
and it's not something I care about we
don't even care about what my kids IQ is
I'm more interested in can you actually
perform or not a SB da you hey Greg I'm
currently transitioning from an
existentialist phase read nagels the
absurd what else can I read similar to
nagels paper
III don't know I'm not I don't read
nagels the absurd but if you're
transitioning out of the existentialist
phase I guess it depends on what you're
trying to get to you know there's a lot
of different ways you could go after
that I would imagine Nagle's work is
probably going to be similar to navels
work so read somewhere if this stuff you
know Alexandro he's about to finish
anthropology and he's got the
opportunity to double major with
philosophy but doesn't know if you
should go to it or go for a masters
instead any advice not sure why you
can't do both you know I don't know
enough about your situation strikes me
as the sort of thing where you wouldn't
have to choose almost you know it's that
you want to get done within a certain
amount of time and the one thing I'll
say is you always have more time to
study you know it's not like the job
situation is gonna get better anytime
soon so you're almost better off being
in in school Alex could you turn on the
automatic closed captions for your
videos I think they are turned on as far
as I know and some of the older ones
might not have it but you know I've been
producing videos now for six seven years
so it would take me a long time to go
back through all the videos and do that
all right Sacco s ever read baritones
creative evolution years and years and
years ago I actually went through kind
of a infatuation with Bergstrom phase
really enjoyed that I I'm more into the
two sources of morality and religion and
is very very early work the essay on the
immediate gibbons of consciousness which
i think is the English translation is
time and free will or something like
that I thought that's interesting stuff
oh here's an interesting one from Trevor
do you think comedies or tragedies work
better for inspiring action why do
almost all of our modern popular stories
end with the good guy winning so that's
that's a tube to big questions right why
do most of our stories end with the good
guy winning I think that's a trend
that's starting to change a little bit
in two ways one is the good guy doesn't
always win in a lot of our newer dramas
and it there's often a lot of murkiness
between good and bad you know think
about things like Breaking Bad or better
call Saul you know or even you know
things that were more formulaic sci-fi
stuff like the Battlestar Galactica
everybody's kind of a mix of good and
bad you know right Cylons aren't totally
wicked now do I think comedies or
tragedies work better for inspiring
action so I mean we would probably frame
this more in terms of like comedies or
dramas right because I guess dramas are
as close to tragedies as we get it
really depends on the content and it
really depends on what you're trying to
do you know neither one seems
particularly great for inspiring the
action though I you know I I think about
if they if they are it's it's not in an
immediate way it's more cumulative you
know you think about like what Star Trek
did for race relations it's not like any
anybody who was racist watched Star Trek
and they're like oh wow you know the
races can
actually work well together I've been
wrong about that but these things we're
on overtime which is part of why
everyone gets so worked up about about
identity politics and representation and
in cultural products you know because
they're out I mean there's always social
engineering going on whether you like it
or not so alright let's let's go on read
52 I've been thinking lately trumpism as
a politics of reason to mount what kind
of critiques do you think nature would
make of the Trump phenomenon I think
nature would say yeah it's a politics
the results of what so would knock
Schaller with his you know
reinterpretation of Hassan's a month and
that goes not just for the you know
proverbial you know poor white voter
who's been left behind out in the rural
areas but also the the rich suburb Trump
motor I think a lot of what what Trump
was tapping into is in fact resentiment
that said I would say that Hillary
Clinton was also a candidate of result
amount as well and that's part of why
you know she was not a very effective
candidate it's gonna be interesting this
time around to who can they put up in
2020 we look at all of the different you
know candidates in the pool and they've
all got problems and this this would be
an interesting conversation to go
through sometime maybe a little bit
boring for some of my non-american
viewers but it's it's something quite
important here and we don't even know if
Trump is gonna survive long enough to
get to the next election
you know because wow he is something
isn't he all right
Alejandro also is a Latin American I'm a
huge fan of Bohr Hayes works so you're -
I was wondering if you're also a fan of
any other Latin American writer I mean
not that I can think of offhand in terms
of like fiction
nobody pops to mind right now there's
probably somebody who I've read and
enjoyed but I can't remember who so
alright read I'm a PhD student in
mathematics I'm glad to hear you
appreciate mathematics did you ever take
a course in mathematical proof no I
never took a course that was only about
mathematical proof but the courses that
I took did have us doing proofs right we
had geometry we did proofs in linear
algebra in number theory and you know
going on and on and on saw but no I
never never never had anything that's
just about mathematical proof Mohamed I
read Nagle is the absurd I'm curious
what other papers and books can I read
that also properly critique
existentialism properly I don't know
there's there's all sorts of to begin
with existentialism is not a thing right
so I would I would guess anybody who
says that there's one thing called
existentialism that doesn't recognize
the diversity between like Kierkegaard
to Nietzsche or Marcel to Simone de
Beauvoir and how Rilke and Kafka can
also fit in there and love chef stuff
they're not really critiquing
existentialism they're critiquing their
little portrayal of existentialism I
mean there's plenty of stuff out there
if you go go into Google Scholar and
type in existentialism criticism and see
what pops up you know and then look for
the stuff that's free cuz it's in PDF
form and read your way through it you
know there's a lot of great sort of
secondary Lit books that that talk about
you know what are the boundaries of
existentialism you know what does it
include you call those critical works to
you know Pisa
the steerer what do you think about
feminism I think feminism is an
ambiguous term so you it's not something
you can really
about if you're asking me whether I
think men and women should be treated
equally yes of course and if you're
asking me whether I think that men and
women in general have about the same
capacities when it's not a matter of
like you know one being oppressed and
being deprived of opportunities that's
been my experience you know I've taught
a lot of male students and female
students I've worked under male chairs
and female chairs and you know I would
like the same opportunities for my
daughter as will exist for my my son now
you know that doesn't mean I have to buy
into various programs and
interpretations and you know to cry of
patriarchy and stuff like that but where
things are patriarchal you'll probably
find me on the side of you know the
people critiquing it because I'm
rational so you know I mean somebody
that I teach routinely as Mary
Wollstonecraft and her vindication of
the rights of women I think is a great
work so that that probably is enough on
that she'll Deleuze are you familiar
with Heidegger's critique of aquinas do
you think it holds up I'm familiar with
it but I don't remember enough about it
and he was critical of Aquinas on a
number of different points so I'm not
sure what we're actually referring to
I mean Heidegger in general is is
critical of everybody before him
including Nietzsche as being meta
physicians who are taking being capital
B and construing it as one region as he
calls it of beings lowercase B so
Aquinas is not unique in that respect a
cart gets that treatment Hegel gets that
treatment
Kant gets that treatment Plato gets that
treatment you know and so on and so
forth oh here's an interesting lesson
mr. Dharma paji what are some of the
best universities for studying
continental philosophy hard for me to
say because
on paper you can look really good and
then when you get there on the ground it
can be quite terrible hey so I mean it
depends is your goal to like do graduate
level work and then go on to try to
teach if that's the case then it's a
much narrower group but if your goal is
just to study it at an undergraduate
level then there's literally hundreds of
places you could go and study
continental philosophy half of which
you're probably gonna have to do on your
own anyway because you know a lot of the
stuff that's cool you're not you're not
actually going to find somebody to teach
that at the time that you want to take
it you know I'll tell you my wife is is
enrolled at European graduate school
which is based in sauce PHA they have
you know big names Jews Butler Slava G
Jack grant Armen right okay and it came
in their teaching it's a very intensive
thing it's a good place to go but I mean
you can also go to Emory or Yale or you
go to well I mean right now you could
actually go to Marquette right down the
road and you take some good continental
philosophy classes there
unfortunately I can't recommend my alma
mater Southern Illinois University which
used to be a great place in part because
the state of Illinois has really gutted
university education there and they've
gone from in my day having about like 14
or 15 full-time professors down to I
think about seven so not good all right
but I mean you can you can go pretty
much anywhere and I'll tell you I'm
gonna take a little digression here I'll
tell you how did I get introduced to
continental philosophy outside of
existentialism which was something that
at least my undergraduate professors
were aware of because they thought at
that time this is how out of the loop
they were there are really three main
things going on in contemporary
philosophy there's existentialism
there's analytic philosophy but don't
bother studying that because that's
gonna kind of die out
nobody really takes that that seriously
back in the early 90s and then there's
process philosophy that's a big going
concern was now I have this this
classmate yoshiya here on Manoa and he
didn't speak English all that well but
he was a really interesting guy came
from a family that was involved in real
estate in Tokyo and he was studying at
Lakeland College and he was taking
philosophy classes and he wrote this
seventy page paper for our our modern
philosophy class and he said my English
isn't very good
I'd like you to present it for me I was
like okay and then he was like now these
books will help you to understand what
I'm referring to there gave me a stack
of books right now in those books were
the losses ant antenna paths right the
losing qatari somebody's gonna crank me
on that of course Bakhtin's problems of
Dostoyevsky's poetics you know dairy
design dermatology you know book after
book after book of sort of contemporary
continental philosophy there was some
Coe in there a whole bunch of stuff
right cool stuff and he was like you can
keep these books I was like are you sure
and he said yeah yeah I can always get
new copies so I kept them and at first
when I read through the stuff I didn't
really understand what the hell I was
getting getting into him but I could
follow the threat of some of it and then
that was the core of some of my lay
library so you know that happened at
Lakeland College so the answer the
question best universities you can study
continental philosophy productively
wherever you are
the an University or out of university
so alright after dying
any thoughts on tania's Gemeinschaft and
Gesellschaft so for those who don't know
this is this distinction between
community and society Tunis was a
sociologist who really early 20th
century a and this is an important book
in influencing people from all over the
the spectrum so I'm some of them were
I'm pretty hard right
some of whom were like you know mock
sailors influenced by the book to some
degree and the idea was that it's not a
radically new idea but Petronius was
giving it kind of a nice analysis you
get can mine shaft which is you know
community it's oriented around people
who know each other and then you've got
this broader ghazzal shaft and that
society and modernity is moving away
from community into society
so you know does that seem to be correct
yeah I mean sure is that the whole story
not really and the idea was that that we
become less psychologically healthy and
less well adapted as we move from
Gemeinschaft and Gesellschaft and also
problems of injustice new problems arise
within gesellschaft that could be true
yeah pit big guns how is the daily life
of a philosophy student well from what I
can remember of it because my day my
daily life as a philosophy student ended
in 2002 it was pretty good plenty of
time to read and think and and you know
I also exercised quite a bit and enjoyed
myself and got involved in relationships
and so you know it was pretty good
what's it like today I can't tell you
I'm not a philosophy student at this
time so the corrupted Channel
so many souls to play with so little
time would you agree not my sort of
thing and what's my favorite creepypasta
I don't I don't do creepypasta my kids
are into that sort of thing but but
that's that's not really I mean it's
definitely I would have time for anyway
if I if I had more time there's other
things I would be doing than that Oh CJ
what's a good book on skepticism well I
mean you probably want to start with sex
- simpiy rockets and outlines of pyro
nism right because that's one of the
original books
so that gets the whole thing started
Alejandra are you a fan of epic poems if
you are what would be your favorite so
that's an interesting on yeah I do like
epic poetry I'm actually rereading
Milton's Paradise Lost at this time for
one of my clients who has me working
with with that to go through it bit by
bit through the arguments I mean I love
the the the Odyssey and the Iliad I like
you know the Song of Roland in part
because I'm doing some work on anger in
the saga Roland because a lot of it
there right the Nibelungen lead I
remember enjoying but I haven't read it
for a long time and I like you know
Comeau Ash's national epic of Portugal
the Lucid odds that's pretty cool stuff
too but I don't actually read that much
epic poetry so Wilhelm my Hegel question
I've reached the middle of the section
of Reason and I'm starting to feel lost
any advice for this section well I mean
it's okay to feel lost just you know
don't don't don't expect too much of
yourself going through it the first or
even second or third time just try to
you know understand each section don't
worry about trying to have like a
comprehensive view of everything if
that's going to happen that will happen
at the end and it might not even happen
you know just go through each of the
dialectics and see what you can make of
it you know we're a little bit over time
I didn't really realize how late it is
but I'm gonna keep on for a bit as I
often do with these since there's
there's many more questions vintage
watch guy do I like any analytic
philosophers I'm hoping you'll look into
Putnam I mean I'm not Putnam actually
came to Southern Illinois University
I've just never found him interesting
yeah there's some analytic philosophers
- I do like they are mostly older ones
you know I'm very interested in it
consign although he's kind of a weird
hybrid sort of character you know I've
read pretty much everybody in the
classical analytic canon and I think
there's good stuff there I really like
John wisdom who doesn't get read very
often and you know I like I like some of
the people who worked within an analytic
idiom but we're bringing in other stuff
like Alice Ambrose you know and I mean
who else I enjoy reading early MacIntyre
which is a analytic philosophy right
I've enjoyed reading Russell even though
I think he's wrong about stuff I
wouldn't read him for history of
philosophy but his you know philosophy
of logical Adam is an interesting book
right so there's plenty of people who I
enjoy cynical skeptic in creating the
mindset of today's liberals who are the
bigger influencers post modernists or
Frankfurt School the answer is neither
neither of them it's it's it's a kind of
a weird funny conservative boogeyman out
there that that liberals most liberals
have actually read any postmodern theory
and understand any of them or the
Frankfurt School
I mean they've mostly read much more
lower grade stuff and you know me let me
also say this when it comes to American
liberals and American conservatives when
it comes to actually reading things that
aren't aimed at it like a sixth to
eighth grade reading level there's not a
hell of a lot of reading going on
conservatives read crap conservative
books in conservative book clubs you
know that all you have to do is look at
it you know a little bit you're like
this is garbage liberals do the same
thing right the stuff you can find you
know walk into a Barnes & Noble politics
section right most of that stuff is just
gar
very few people are actually reading
much theory there's a lot of references
but you know that doesn't mean that
people have actually read and been
influenced by by stuff very much all
right
proof architect who and what works do
you recommend reading in order to
successfully understand the
existentialist movement you're gonna get
the same answer that you typically get
from me read primary sources
you know don't dick around with with
reading secondary books first read some
Kierkegaard then read some Dostoevsky
then read some Nietzsche then read some
Rilke then read some chef's stuff you
know I'm going through the chronological
order right then read some yah Spurs
then read some Heidegger and some Ortega
y Gasset some Sartre and some you know
Marsala just read the primary texts
Kafka of course in there too because you
know why life is in some respects too
short to waste on just reading glosses
of great literature read read you know
the actual stuff Andrew grant what would
I say is sacred so you're probably
asking me personally what I think is is
sacred right I do think that there's a
divine and I think that you know I'm
kind of in some respects and you know
politeness in that respect I think it
pervades the in the the domain of
eminence that that were within and we
can connect ourselves up to it in
different ways but it's often quite
difficult you know I've said this many
times before and I'll say it one more
time here I like reading religious
thinkers for whom religion doesn't solve
problems but it actually makes things
much more complicated because that's
probably closer to reality you know when
you've got a neat you know theory that
solves everything and tells you where
everything fits it's probably [ __ ]
so yeah Robert where should when should
a country intervene in the affairs of
another country why doesn't the West
adopt the millenarian position of
benevolent despotism well if you if
you're asking me personally I am an
interventionist when it comes to major
human rights abuses so like if you take
for example the fact that we've you know
just recently say we the United States
you know just bombed Syria along with
France and and Great Britain and we
bombed some chemical deposits boy that's
way too a little too late you know now
does that mean that we can just engage
in military adventures
wherever no as a matter of fact we
probably shouldn't be the policemen of
the world the United States and I'm for
you know as a vet I'm for caring back
our military considerably and certainly
cutting expenses and cutting them in
terms of plenty of things that we're
wasting money on you know but I you know
I think that when we see massive human
rights abuses genocide taking place it
makes sense for somebody to intervene
now getting that to actually happen it's
quite difficult right why doesn't the
West adopt the benevolent despotism I'm
not even sure what that would look like
so yeah Ryan what is the current
professional philosophical landscape
like pretty crappy not a lot of jobs the
people who go to the elite schools can
suck up the jobs and then tell everybody
that they got it on the basis of their
talent which it's not really the case
it's mostly on the basis of their
connections and pedigree and you know
it's it's a it's tough to make it you
could say professionally you know it's
probably good to have a side gig you
know like like what I do I you know
I work in a number of other fields I
still do teach occasionally but that's
if that was my only income I would be
screwed you know I don't know how we
would possibly live I gotta take a brief
pause here my wife is asking me how my
ama went I'm gonna tell her still in it
all right
so let's take some more questions should
shadaab why do you think stoicism isn't
more mainstream well it's pretty
mainstream you know as far as
philosophies go when you got you know
online groups that have you know tens of
thousands of members and you're able to
have you know meetups all over the world
and it's being talked about in you know
not just philosophy circles but in all
sorts of professional circles and and
you know I give workshops on this stuff
too you know companies and businesses
and I do philosophical counseling with
people it's pretty mainstream certainly
compared to Aristotelian ism or even
existentialism so you know I think you
have to put that in perspective you
might say well yeah but there's a hell
of a lot more books about I don't know
yoga then there are stoicism yeah yoga
is more popular but you know I think the
modern Stoics are doing a pretty good
job in in outreach compared to other
philosophical schools
Fahim can we compare plato's communism
theory with Marxism communism sure you
can do that you know they're they're
different regimes that set up in
different ways and they're focused
around different issues so I don't know
what points you want to compare them on
they're definitely different types of
communism so proof architect why do you
think Bertrand Russell is an inadequate
history of philosophy professor because
history philosophy is crap I mean don't
have to ask me ask plenty of other you
know people who do history of philosophy
do you think Bertrand Russell's history
of philosophy is good and yeah you're
not gonna find many people saying yes he
misconstrues people you know you this is
a problem in in history of philosophy
you know you if you have to actually
spend time with the texts trying to
think through that perspective not have
an agenda that you're already going to
it with Russell doesn't do that you know
and there's plenty of other people who
do you know entertaining but not very
good history of philosophy you know yeah
I'm not singling him out in that respect
Ricky what is meant by a platonic
dialogue well you know Plato wrote
dialogues where you have these
characters and they are talking about
philosophical issues and quite often
there's a dramatic situation with it and
they not only talk about and endorse or
question or critique philosophical
positions they often represent
philosophical positions that's an
important part of the the Philip the
platonic dialogue another thing too is
the platonic dialogue often encompasses
other genres so a great example of this
is Plato's symposium where Plato is able
to write in a lot of other people's
styles he's got Pazhani as this legal
expert he gives a speech that's Plato
writing the speech then Eric Zemeckis
you know doctor physician gets up and
gives it a rather dry academic speech
Plato is able to do that Plato is even
able to imitate Aristophanes and
gorgeous in Agathon so you know pretty
high level of art there okay wig Ren how
come you find Hegel more interesting
than can't I don't actually I just you
know I started working on Hegel I did
the half hour Hegel project in part
because I pulled my viewers about five
years ago six years ago who they wanted
and the answers were Heidegger Sartre
Mark Cuza and Hegel so I started doing
that existentialism series that I still
really do need
finish waiting till I get to a
sufficient level of patreon support
before I take that on though because I
have to have you know the patreon money
is what allows me to be able to spend
time you know doing this rather than
just working directly with with clients
or stuff like that cuz I have to earn a
living I don't have a university backing
me or the state backing me so so I did
that first right and then I started the
half-hour hagel project in part because
people were asking for Hegel but I've
done plenty of stuff on Khan's
philosophy and I've done you know class
sessions and videos
other than cons interesting I'm not a
couching or a Hegelian you know any more
than I'm a Cartesian or something like
that
Jordan what's your thoughts on Alfred
North Whitehead and process philosophy
so very interesting stuff I have not
read process and reality for a long time
I would love to have the time to do it
but you know I don't know if I'll ever
find the time again to do it again
that's the sort of thing where if I get
enough support then that affords me the
time to be able to do those those sorts
of things
Heraclitus appeases what do I think of
shelling again somebody interesting who
I haven't read much recently read a good
bit of you know back in grad school but
I don't I just don't get the time to you
know you get you you only get 24 hours a
day and I'm so busy doing the projects
that I'm doing and and you know engaged
with the work that I'm doing that I just
don't unfortunately get to a lot of
these thinkers Albert what do you think
it means to know yourself if the self is
constantly changing well it's kind of a
non-starter I don't think the self is
constantly changing I think that there's
there's some changes that go on but I
don't know that we don't have some
continuity right oh wow there's a lot of
questions here that I don't know we'll
get to all of a suddenly refreshed it
looks like I've got double the questions
I was being asked before
so I'm gonna have to skip through them
fairly quickly I'll try to finish this
up in about ten minutes or so
let's see here
[Music]
and scroll down
oh yes maybe or Jesus what other
emotions interest you so I I do work out
anger what are the other emotions that
interest me
as well I mean when I'm working with
clients fear anxiety that's something
they're important the nature of our
desires and aversions is something that
I think is quite interesting too so but
I I'm not into I am more interested in
anger than anything else you know all
right
oh wow Vikings what century do you think
was the most productive and conversely
not so productive for philosophy so I
mean there were there are plenty of
century is that at least in Western
philosophy were not that productive
during the some parts of the Middle Ages
because there wasn't that much activity
going on right but I mean the last
century wow there's so much stuff you
couldn't possibly read it all but even
like you know in in the ancient period
there there's so much going on in every
century that I don't know how you would
get through all of it
rabbie rabbit yes have you read demons
from Dostoevsky that is actually in fact
my favorite work by Dostoevsky the
demons or the possessed is how its
translated I like those that worked
quite a lot all right I'm gonna skip
down a bit
oh here's an important dr. Sandler I
can't find a lecture on book three of
the Republic am I not seeing it or do
not have one uploaded the lectures that
you see are from my classes so if we
didn't cover it in my class then I I
didn't get to it
if you want me to to be able to get to
that sort of stuff I'm gonna put it
they're plugged for patreon right that's
that's where people start to have kind
of like a mouthpiece in getting to
suggest things because I only have so
much time available all right I'm gonna
scroll down and see if I can take some
that that are other people didn't who
haven't gotten heard yet
so here's an interesting one from
Skywalker does being a fatalist help you
survive the capitalist society it might
not it might seem like it's a good thing
to do so that you're not being affected
by stuff it's just the way it goes right
but maybe if you adopt that perspective
you don't you know say no when you
should or you don't like start looking
around for ways out when when there
actually are some some ways out all
right let's see here how much do you
lift not that much as a matter of fact I
I do the circuit machines and you know
the numbers on them don't really
correspond to anything in terms of free
weights as far as I can tell but I have
to you know I gotta get in shape and so
you start with what you what you can so
I you know I got a trainer and he set me
up with here's where the seat should go
here's what wait to put on this thing
and I'm you know I'm going to two three
times a week and doing the circuit the
weight circuit thing and then two to
three times a week I also do a one-hour
cardio thing as well but boy when you're
in your 40s getting back in shape is
nothing like trying to get back in shape
when you're in your 20s unfortunately so
oh that's a nice Rob rub that says
thanks for taking the time to do these
you're a saint and a scholar I am a
scholar and definitely nice
in fact people always ask me about my my
religious views and now you know I do
believe in God and I'm just not on
particularly good terms with him at this
time in my life I'm one of these people
who kind of wrestles with God more than
anything else but yeah so definitely not
a saint but a lot of chatter back and
forth people attack each other these
comments not quite sure why things that
generated like that well yeah a lot of
back and forth in this mmm here's an
interesting one from MS doctors together
why is theology not philosophy
considered the cornerstone in humanities
departments that's an interesting
question because I don't think either
one is these days most humanities
departments from what I can tell tend to
be run by the English people you know or
the history people who always have
greater numbers anyway because we don't
teach philosophy in in K through 12 here
in the United States so you know we do
we do teach English and social studies
so they always have much larger
representation than we philosophers do
unfortunately let me scroll down some
more kapha Jake where is he reading
these questions from well there's a
control room in in these broadcast
things and it should be like it should
be something that you're able to see on
the side I imagine because that's how
they're set up
oh here's the crew from averroes of tell
fear what's with that beard professor
you'd probably get more dates without it
well I think that my wife then is
probably pretty happy that I have the
beard I am happily married and then for
for quite a long time with with somebody
who I met
in high school who is genuinely an equal
to me you know I'm really fortunate in
my choice a choice I guess choice does
enter into it but in the partner who I
have finally wound up with and you know
I don't know that I would ever want to
get rid of the beard I'm getting kind of
lazy right that's why it's getting long
like that I probably should give it a
trim but I've had the beard so long now
that it feels weird not to have a beard
so I'll probably stick with it for good
it's part of my look now right I
actually posted some pictures in my
social media of me without a beard from
a while back and boy doesn't look like
me
so all right let me think in just a few
more ms Miraz tall / when will he give
us a lecture on science of logic by
Hegel I would consider that when I
finish with the half hour Hegel series
of the phenomenology which would
probably be two years from now but there
would have to be some really big backing
for me to take on the logic that's
that's a lot of work to do and that's
tougher and there are some great
lectures out there already on the logic
so I think other people you know are
doing that sort of work alright so I'm
gonna take one more question that I
think is a good one to end on do I think
David Hume disproves what the Stoics
believed concerning reason being able to
create a moral system and improve
humanity we could ask similarly with
like Nietzsche other stuff like that the
answer is no you know humans famous for
saying reason should only be the slave
of the passions right and there's two
things to say about that one is simply
asserting that doesn't prove a damn
thing that's just an assertion right in
order for it to mean
something in terms of you know
critiquing anybody else's philosophy
whether it's the Stoics or whether it's
a contour whether it's just a cart you
know anybody who's got sort of a more
rationalist frame of mind Aristotle for
that matter right there's got to be more
there than just asserting well Hume said
X Y Z because who gives a [ __ ] what him
said if it's just X Y Z you've got to
have something more than that so the
underlying argumentation right
what did Hume a actually say did he
really say that that's the whole story
that reason should just be the slave of
the passions no what he's saying is that
reason by itself is not going to drive
everything and then you can also look at
humans own work which is pretty
rationalistic and say okay so why did
you say this about justice over here and
why did you advise this you know and as
it turns out what Hume is really trying
to tell us is we do need to take into
account the effective much more than we
are doing we can't just think that bite
we're just gonna like reason our way
into goodness and that's not what the
stoic say the Stoics aren't saying well
you just like exercise force a will and
you know apply reason and everything
falls into place no it's a continual
reworking of our desires and you have to
actually understand how they work and
what's what's going on and and get to
the point where you have one you know
epic teens for example says when it
comes to desire you're not trying to get
rid of it altogether you're trying to
focus it on the things that you actually
can control and in those things you're
really you know gonna be looking at
those quite hard you should be averse to
like you know being a screw-up you
should desire to have a well integrated
life and so the Stoics and humor not as
far apart from each other as people
might make them out to be even Contin
him or not as far apart from each other
as people might make them out to be and
so I think that's a good place to end
here so great questions from everybody
and we'll do these a you know every
month
thanks to my patreon supporter
so if you're not a supporter you should
thank some of the supporters out there
for you know helping me to continue
doing this sort of work and we do have
another philosophy pop up coming up
later this month on Facebook so go to my
facebook page all announced that their
patreon supporters find out in advance
about it everybody else finds out the
day of and I don't think we have any
other online events but I do have some
videos coming out that I've been
recording I got you know we did the
sci-fi series we talked about al Sprague
de Kamp
earlier this week so I'm going to be
editing that stuff that should come out
next week few other interesting things
coming up and of course this video will
be available as well so alright see all
of you hope you have a great day if
you're here in this hemisphere great
evening or early morning if you're in
the other hemisphere and I'll see you in
the ether somewhere else